and a woman which doesn't mind and then
so China do you count like you know like
so if a man is
is gotten his his woman he's faithful
and all that so do you count the
occasional times when he kind of trips
and falls into the finals
well you know what it is
there was an episode I was like what did
you do triple fall in this because he's
like oh now he's like he's switching it
right he's like whatever man trips or
forces that occasional trip I'm falling
do you count as being outside that's not
been outside oh so look I'm gonna just
put I'll be like this so like 40-year
marriage he hooks up with a couple you
know a girl every couple of years
another one so at this point like
if your wife if you're telling your
wifey it's good so if telling your wife
he's gonna cause you to destroy your
relationship then you know what you're
doing in it I just think
I've seen friends do stuff loving their
misses and acting like they don't and
then they do something they get caught
and they lose their misses and it
destroys a man's life don't be one of
those guys so yeah so whatever you do
just be prepared for in it because if
after 40 years you might be in the
comments crying about oh my wife is
taking half in it you know what I mean
so I just yeah you need to know the type
of relationship you have because some
women will allow that one woman you do
that once she's taking everything so you
have to know the type of woman that you
have it's your type of woman that will
forgive you will forgive it's the type
of woman that's going to be like you
know as long as it wasn't the resources
she's gonna ask you so what did you do
what have you been buying this girl
stuff what did you know like if you
discovers that you know you've been
paying for a flat you bought you've been
dude like she might say okay now I want
to take take half but if she just knows
that it was one of those things she'd be
like you know I don't want to split up
the family the kids don't have to know
go buy me some maybe you have to go and
do some stuff to to make up for it but I
just think man them whatever you do just
just do it with your chest I don't I
don't understand like I don't understand
it how like guys will have the time and
the energy to like live two lives we're
like it's different if you've got two
wives and everyone knows everything
there but when you know when like guys
literally live like a whole lie do you
know what I mean I don't have a whole
family on the side and it's just that
level of stress like you're not trying
to accomplish anything in your life like
I met um I met a guy that he told me he
was the youngest in his family
and
um he had four older siblings
and he said my older sibling is from a
different woman because his his um
father got the side chick pregnant and
the mom stayed with him and was
literally there when the side chick gave
birth Madness wait was this my was this
my boy
you don't know no no do you know why
because I literally know the same story
the same story no no but it's literally
I mean this was in the U.S no this is
the UK yeah yeah yeah yeah I I was like
oh my God that like that is another
level
good woman when I say good woman I don't
mean like when people say oh he's a real
man for stepping up but I just mean some
women would love you so much that
they're gonna like you know what I mean
like I mean I think I could get over a
lot but oh my God that's like a kid that
would be hard that would be a kid you're
breaking up your family bro
ideally I like to think I wouldn't but I
think it would be really hard for me to
actually forgive a guy that he got
another girl pregnant it's just the
irresponsibility of it like if you're
gonna do it at least like don't get
another girl pregnant yeah yeah like any
of the drama I just yeah I think that
would really piss me off but I think I
think it's probably because
um if there's no kid involved you guys
can pattern it and kind of lie but once
as a kid
you gotta introduce the kid to like the
family
tell your sister is like I live a little
stressed man I can't even imagine like
how hot your head would be at that point
I
yeah I
I mean that I think would be really hard
to forgive would you accept if he's just
stepping up but not uh getting anyone
pregnant
do we have kids no
kids I mean were we are we married no
you're in a relationship oh um
that's an interesting question I like to
say no but I think if I'm being truly
honest with myself or the right guy I
probably would and I let I like to think
I wouldn't oh how many times
oh how many times how many laugh lines
does he get
um
I think if it's like uh we're not even
married yet he's already doing it
um I think if it's like this is all okay
this is all like a prediction yeah and I
just know that like for the right guy
that I would put up with a lot and I
think most girls for the right guy would
put up with a lot I don't know how many
times does it disqualify him from being
the right guy if he's doing that to me
it would
um I like that in I the idea of it but I
just think I'm being real when I say
um I don't know the right guy could get
away with a lot what about they were all
hot chicks he was who were you quoting
with like you looked at them when you
was like yeah they were super hot
um
oh God I don't know this is all like a
prediction right like
um for a small part of you might respect
him more if they're like yeah
which is usually the case to be fair
when guys step out it's usually for
girls it's just like I've witnessed
other girls and it's like and they've
stayed for the right guy and I've stayed
before when someone like cheated and so
it's like how can I say I wouldn't if I
did and also I remember my mom said this
to me when I was younger I didn't
understand it um because one of my
sisters was was dating someone and she
was like oh I'm almost like I've got
someone from Africa for you and you
should try to hook her up I'm like Mom
she's got a man like what are you doing
she's like mom's like
um like so what that's just a boyfriend
what does it matter in it and I never
understood it about that time but you
know when they say it's not it's not
yours it's just your turn literally
that's all it is the only reason that
women have body caps is because they've
been with all these type of guys that
did not actually turn out to be anything
that was going to be anything tangible
so
if a girl says I've got a man and she
hasn't got a ring she's open game
everyone's open game you you haven't
like and it's the truth for the matter
you might not like it yeah yeah sorry
sorry oh yeah but it's just that if you
haven't got a ring and you're not mad
you're single and that's how the
government looks at it and that's how
people look the only reason I won't
speak to you when you're outside is if I
have a ring on your finger I know some
people will but the one way to guarantee
that you will not get attention is when
a man looks and he sees a ringer but
like she's taken apart from that
everyone's pregame
I just think that like as women were
attracted to certain type of guys and
you know if a guy has all the like all
the things that you look for he might
cheat yeah so how can I how can I be
that mad if he cheats when it's like I
picked him but I think it takes quite a
secure woman to be able to actually
forgive it I I know it sounds
counterproductive but if you've got
secure in yourself and you can forgive
really easily I think you'll be able to
forgive it but I think if you're really
insecure it just ignites your
insecurities even more and then it falls
apart so it actually makes you more
secure for staying I think yeah well I
think the K I don't know if I could do
the kid I think that would be
cool I don't know where the line is but
I think it's a child it's like it's like
for men like they're also a woman
cheated on me now she's out the door but
then I don't have kids the one when I
say she had kids it's one of those ones
then we then we say oh sorry then we say
um okay has was it is it public is it
embarrassment you start trying to damage
control because you're thinking right
what can I well how can I say face what
can we recover from here because we have
kids right but if you don't have kids
I'm going to be outside but if we do
have kids I'll be real with you I'll be
thinking more about trying to trying to
but what can I do where at that point
you'd probably start stepping out though
it would be like yeah oh yeah
all right I'll forgive you like no one
knows I'll forgive you but like yeah I'm
not upset
we'll turn into whole swingers over here
we're dropping our keys in the bow
everything I have a different opinion on
when women cheat especially in a
marriage though yeah because I feel like
when a woman cheats in a marriage that
that is more than just emotions and I
feel like
there is that element of higher not
really understanding how dangerous a
man's life is in terms of the fact that
you're going to go and sleep with
another man when you have your whole
family with a different man that's like
that's like literally
starting like a war you know
but I think at least with me with women
I think you can actually prevent a woman
from cheating but I don't think he can
prevent a man from cheating please tell
me how you can prevent it I think a man
can be very happy and satisfied and
still step out but I think with a woman
the moment she feels some neglect that's
when her things are heightened when
she's not neglected she's tends to be
more loyal neglect leads to I think when
women cheats because they think they can
do better but I think neglect determines
whether they think they can do better I
think a man that's not neglecting you
you think okay I'm upset but when he
starts neglecting you you think I can do
better I just I think you're either that
guy to hurry or not I think it also
depends on the type of girl in it like
if she's got her Tendencies and you
marry her
like she might not even feel neglected
but she's just maybe because I the
career I do I work with couples and
stuff a lot but I see men who are
millionaires and they're they're lives
are cheating with like a guy who's got a
bed set in like a Camden or something
that's too horny and no no because she
just needed to feel because he was Alpha
because she married the guy for the
resources and she wanted the sex when a
woman hasn't been given attention I'm
not saying it's a good thing but I do
think women are so attention driven that
when if you give her enough attention
she'll manage no no no no no because
what you're doing is you keep removing
it's like we have to give him an
accountability women married these guys
for resources yeah it was never the guy
which which set heart on fire but she
married for since remember I said she
married what makes sense right now the
problem with when you marry for what
makes sense and even when you're married
condition [__] it doesn't matter if
it's 20 years at some point she can step
outside because she has it inside what
did she think she was marrying if he's
like like that that's the sorry I'm
sorry that just sounds so stupid to me
like from from her the girl who says
that because it's like my mom's married
to that guy my dad would go to India for
weeks at a time trying to get build
their company up but she knew he was a
workaholic you can't have like women
like we think we can have everything and
now you're gonna say oh I'm neglected
because my husband's going to work to
provide for my family so I'm gonna cheat
that's the most [__] that's the
stupidest thing I've ever heard
and I don't want to think like my mom is
and I would never do this to a woman
like what what I've seen my parents
sacrifice for us for this first
generation is it's things that people
could never even do now because the
selfishness and you know I mean I watch
my parents live in two separate
countries still together but because of
that they gave their five children the
best opportunities to come into this
country as the first generation from
Cameroon right so it's like it's like
by what you say my dad fully neglected
my mom you know what the difference is
there though they had a joint Mission
yeah they're literally they're the
common goal and they were both working
towards certain in your example it's the
woman just marrying for resources that's
that's shallow but I would say that the
same thing like when a man has a woman
that's looking after their kids and
doing all of that being and then he
steps out because he just wants to have
sex isn't that just equally as [__]
it's not the same thing I think the same
would be him funding another woman yes
that's that's more yeah yeah so wouldn't
that be the case if a woman is at like
how a man's providing for you and you're
just because you feel neglected and
you're cheating which I think is
ridiculous but it does happen
um wouldn't it be the same kind of
philosophy when a woman's looking after
your kids and being loyalty and cleaning
your house and cooking for you and
because she's not as sexy as she used to
be you're stepping out no do you know I
mean the same disrespect no I think the
equivalent is him spending money on
another girl
having a full side chick that he pays
her right I think that is take a dent in
your pocket though no even the fact that
if you're taking resources because at
that moment you know like
see at that moment you know it's more
than that like I never understand when
guys got girls and they step up but they
don't want to step out Pearl they
actually have like they start taking
girls on dates and stuff I'm like bro
what are you that's what I was saying
earlier like it's Madness
how do you have enough energy to be
dealing with that but the reason they do
this is because like their home lights
are [__] boring and they grow in a
boring and women is looking after their
kids no but yeah but you're boring
they're going to meet a girl and she's
exciting right if he starts financially
funding her says you know I'm gonna pay
for you your studies yo he's cheating in
a different way how do you guys say it's
not about better it's just about
different yeah
there's nothing wrong you can't stop a
man because they just like varieties no
but if we look at if it works so if when
your wife cheats on you it's so much
deeper because in order for a woman to
do that she has to have some type of
emotion some women on demon time yeah
and we don't really talk about those
women because those are the women that
will just do whatever right but what
generally
to make your misses that loved you and
was only sleeping with you to go and
open her leg so next your missus is gone
she's not coming back your man's gonna
go do that he's gonna get post not
Clarity he's like oh my God I love my
girl let me go buy something
yeah but I can't equate it sexy in in
infidelity the same not to men not to
men because then what's gonna happen is
but how could you you had to have been
turned on by her to be no men were hole
in the wall and I'm not trying to make
it better I'm just trying to say I'm
trying to say he's different so if you
judge yourself by that you will never
understand why he can truly love you and
cheat yeah like you know what I mean do
you think there's certain cultures of
men that cheat more than others or do
you think it's all men I don't think
it's so this whole I I think that
certain types of men cheat more so like
if you're gonna date an NBA player or
um and like you know versus like the
computer nerd I feel like the commute
computer nerd is less likely to do it
they're pretty boiled down to options
though again
like the NBA player is going to have mad
options so it's a lot more difficult for
him not to cheat
you get these guys that say I've never
cheated in my life I've never stepped up
you
actually can't go and draw another girl
but like for the guys that have girls
throwing themselves at him it's a lot
more difficult no you're right I think
that like like take Tiger Woods
I mean he had a bus I think mostly yeah
and I used to I used to disagree with
this but then I was like you know what
if most guys had a Bus full of models
begging to sleep with them at the end of
the of a long hard day at work are they
gonna say no for 40 50 probably not
there's probably even a good man like
one day he's just gonna be like you know
what she's hot they're ready and her
Tiger Woods situation as well like going
golf golfers there traveling all around
the world
you know I mean
still yeah International
there's women
I'm surprised he lost it that long
enough
it's the fact that he was doing that and
he was still had a top game can you
imagine how the levels he was yeah it
was literally dealing with all these
women and he was just knock it in the
hole yeah this guy's a g we got Tiger
Woods man
maybe it motivated him he was like I
need to get more models
but like yeah no like yeah like no um
for so I actually think when most when
these men cheat you know they don't
cheat because they want to cheat right
I'm not taking the responsibility away
from them but men are weak and women
know how women are
some women can be S so what's the word
unoffensive like they so forward didn't
it and when you put a man that's got
these status got this Cloud got his
riches the types of women that go up to
him like you know yeah like you know and
then some you know used to always get
caught like Ashley Cole and John Terry
you will see the woman that would cheat
with and you'd be like bruh you just
want to understand man that's the worst
day when you realize you have to worry
about ugly girls too oh my God
ugly ugly fat girls that can cook you
need to worry about these women with
good attitudes oh hey these are the this
is the one that you slim women need to
worry about this is all you buy it's
hard as a woman because you can be
everything and you can still get rid
that's still an option like you you can
still cheat and that's not a problem so
that's why it's a bit harder in that
sense but I also think here it's the
west Western
like sit Pearl when did it become
cheating when did it change from like
pulling me to not like when did it
because what do you mean like
because I know it wasn't always like
this I knew like at different times
people used to get on like one man would
you know have a certain women some men
wouldn't get women and that's just how
it was well the divorce rate skyrocketed
with the development of birth control
um and that's like when the divorce rate
started to happen
so the 60s yeah so we need to get rid of
birth control
well I mean they've been taking me
don't tempt me no but what I've
discovered about birth control is that
is like I didn't know it made girls mood
now it changes the type of guy you're
attracted to too so you're more
attracted like it your body is pregnant
so it tricks your butt like that's how
you don't get pregnant it tricks your
body into thinking you're pregnant so
what happens is like then when a girl's
pregnant she's looking for more of a
provider guy so she might pick a guy and
then get off of birth control and not
even be attracted to her husband I've
I've heard stuff like I've heard of that
yeah yeah it's black I just know like in
like with my girl or not yeah she said
that she don't she don't take those
stuff and then that was the first time I
probably you know like because all the
other women that I've dealt with I've
dealt with birth control and they're
crazy so I think it um
when I hear that and and I think it
makes sense because when they say I
don't want to take that because I don't
wanna and it could make me not like you
I heard that what do you mean you could
make me not like yeah you might just
turn around I don't like you anymore
yeah because it changes the type of guy
you pick and you're attractive I thought
she was Captain when she said no that's
true
that's true so I mean you could argue
that the divorce rate went up I saw a
theory about this the other day and I
thought it was interesting that maybe
the divorce rate went up because girls
are on birth control when they picked
their husbands and then after they got
the kids they weren't attracted to them
anymore
I don't know if that's true it's just a
theory I heard yeah I don't want to
remind them don't risk it don't start
gonna
imagine she just comes off at one that
realizes like I don't actually like
you're ugly
it's hard it's not it's a hard one don't
they because it's like it's like kids no
kids like it's difficult unless you want
to be just cheating with condoms the
whole time which is slowly
but you know you're supposed to do it I
saw um
I'm about oh yeah
um every guy I had sex with I had sex
with my periods yeah
she's like and I was like oh that's a
whole blood ritual there that's all it's
actually funny but you do realize that's
what they used to do do in the olden
days that's how they guaranteed not
you're not getting pregnant in that
they'll have sex during the period and
when you wanted to get pregnant is when
you have sex I swear you can still get
pregnant
shoot up in a club of sort of heard as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tic Tac and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible